so this is a story all about how my lounge
got flipped
turned upside down and if you'd like to
take a minute
just sit right there and I'll tell you about
how I painted it
six different colours
and unfortunately
I'm not even talking about these test pots
I'm talking about how I genuinely tried and
committed to six different colours
before finding the right combination
the first thing you should know is I'm an idiot
clearly
and the second thing you should know is this took 6 months
I started with this half of the room and
I clearly painted it mustard
bold fkn choice. I don't hate it at this point tho
and then I turned around and saw this in the other half of the room
and I thought hell
my mental health is already unstable
why not push it and try and get this room done
I don't know 5 days before Christmas
and spoiler alert
we did not make the Christmas deadline
I don't know why I'm surprised
and as a mother of three I don't even know why I tried
I did manage to seal the walls so that they didn't look so
I don't know hideous
the day before 25 people came to my house for Christmas
hands up if you’re also always the host
and then this I'm ashamed to say this is New Year's Eve
looking back at this footage
I can't help but laugh like what the fk was I actually up to
I should say as well this is never seen before footage
and there's a reason it's never been seen before
and that is because
I was immediately filled with deep regret over my decision making
so this room actually this whole house is very
Mid century and as you can see
there's a panel that divides
like the top third of the room from the rest of the room
and I really like it when people paint their ceilings an interesting colour
and I thought
maybe I could be one of those interesting people with interesting ceilings
and I've gotta say mustard is about as interesting as it gets
and obviously white wouldn't have looked any good with it
side note nothing would have look up with it
so I ended up complimenting that bold mustard with this soft
kind of limoncello colour
by the way this is no shade at the paint or the colours
they are absolutely lovely
it just wasn't lovely placement on my behalf
looking back on it now it was definitely a vibe like it does look cool
it looks like a cool retro TV set but living in it
it was maybe a bit much for this room anyway
because I have since realised that this room is actually a fkn
nightmare to work with I'm not sure if you've noticed
but there are a lot of different things going on in this room
there's two different spaces, a lot of little surfaces, built in shelves
like there's just a lot going on
but when it comes to paint
I subscribe to the philosophy that you should
absolutely push the boat out
and try something new and if you don't like it
you can just cut your losses and change it
it's pretty cheap pretty accessible
and it's a fun DIY
I'm telling myself that to make myself feel better
but seriously I'm just so fkn sick of white
she says as she has just finished painting the walls white
and to be totally honest
painting the mustard out of this room did make me a bit sad
but it just wasn't working in the other area
and considering these two spaces are connected
it's got to be cohesive so it's gotta go
and so I sampled and my little mind boggled
turns out I'm quite indecisive
generally though I'm not that indecisive
I swear it's just the curse of this room anyway
so I sampled another colour
this is Potter's Park by Dulux
and I absolutely love it but did I love it here in this particular space
no I did not
I would like to put it anywhere else
just not here maybe in my daughter's bedroom
or maybe even the creepy laundry
so once I had successfully made a bad room worse
by painting random swatches all over it
so that it closely resembled the inside of my brain
ha ha messy
I made the executive decision
to boss my husband into painting everything white
and it stayed like this for quite a while actually
I needed a beat okay
this room had traumatised me
and I lost all my confidence in colour
but then one day recently
I thought I'd try again I thought I'd try this one
and I thought this one might be the one
her name is Ponsonby she is from Dulux
and she is stunning as stunning as she is
I mean they're all stunning
but I just I wasn't feeling it
so now we're on to colour No. 6
and I’ll have to let you know how we go in the next part